[Music]
I'm sure that you're already familiar
with the whole pie versus Tao debate a
lot of people say that the fundamental
circle constant we hold up should be the
ratio of a circles circumference to its
radius which is around six point two
eight not the ratio to its diameter the
more familiar 3.14 these days we often
call that larger constant Tao
popularized by Michael hurdles Tau
manifesto although personally I'm quite
partial to Robert police's proposed
notation of a pie with three legs in
either of these manifestos and on many
many other places of the internet you
can read to no end
about how many formulas look a lot
cleaner using Tao largely because the
number of radians describing a given
fraction of a circle is actually that
fraction of tau that Deadhorse is beat
I'm not here to make that case further
instead I'd like to talk about the
seminal moment in history when PI as we
know it became the standard for this one
fruitful place to look is that the old
notes and letters by one of history's
most influential mathematicians Leonardo
Euler luckily we now have an official
three blue one Brown Switzerland
correspondent Ben hum Brecht who was
able to go to the library in Euler's
hometown and get his hands on some of
the original documents and in looking
through some of those it might surprise
you to see oiler write let PI be the
circumference of a circle whose radius
is one that is the six point two eight
constant that we would now call tau and
it's likely he was using the Greek
letter pi as AP for perimeter so was it
the case that Euler genius of the day
was more notationally enlightened than
the rest of the world fighting the good
fight for 6.28
and if so who's the villain of our story
pushing the 3.1415 constant shoved in
front of most students today well the
work that really established PI as we
now know it as the commonly recognized
circle constant was an early calculus
book from 1748 at the start of chapter 8
in describing the semi circumference of
a circle with radius one and after
expanding out a full 128 digits of this
number one of them wrong by the way the
author adds which for the sake of
brevity I may write PI now there were
other texts and letters here and there
with varying conventions for the
notation of various circle
since but this book and this section in
particular was really the one to spread
the notation throughout Europe and
eventually the world so what monster
wrote this book with such an
unprincipled take towards circle
Constance
well Euler again in fact if you look
further you can find instances of Euler
using the symbol pi to represent a
quarter turn of the circle what we would
call today PI halves or tau fourths in
fact Euler's use of the letter pi seems
to be much more analogous to our use of
the Greek letter theta it's typical for
us to let it represent an angle but no
one angle in particular sometimes it's
30 degrees maybe other times it's 135
and most times it's just a variable for
a general statement it depends on the
problem and the context before us
likewise Euler let PI represent whatever
circle constant best suited the problem
before him though it's worth pointing
out that he typically framed things in
terms of unit circles with radius 1 so
the 3.1415 constant would almost always
have been thought of as the ratio of a
circles semi circumference to its radius
none of this circumference to its
diameter nonsense and I think Oilers use
of this symbol carries with it a general
lesson about how we should approach math
the thing you have to understand about
Euler is that this man solved problems a
lot of problems I mean day in day out
breakfast lunch and dinner he was just
turning out puzzles and formulas and
having insights and creating entire new
fields left and right over the course of
his life he wrote over 500 books and
papers which amounted to a rate of 800
pages per year and these are dense math
pages and then after his death another
400 publication surfaced it's often
joked that formulas and math have to be
named after the second person to prove
them because the first is always going
to be Euler his mind was not focused on
what circle constant we should take his
fundamental he was on solving the task
sitting in front of him in a particular
moment than writing a letter to the
bernoulliís to boast about doing so
afterwards for some problems the
quarter-circle constant was most natural
to think about for others the full
circle constant and for others still say
at the start of chapter 8 of his famous
calculus book maybe the half circle
constant was most natural to think about
too often in math education the focus is
on which of multiple competing views
about a topic is right
is it correct to say that the sum of all
positive integers is negative 1/12 or is
it correct to say that it diverges to
infinity can the infinitesimal values of
calculus be taken literally or is it
only correct to speak in terms of limits
are you allowed to divide a number by
zero these questions in isolation just
don't matter
our focus should be on specific problems
and puzzles both those of practical
application and those of idle pondering
for knowledge as own sake
then when questions of standards arise
you can answer them with respect to a
given context and inevitably different
contexts will lend themselves to
different answers of what seems most
natural but that's ok outputting 800
pages a year of dense transformative
insights seems to be more correlated
with a flexibility towards conventions
than it does with focusing on which
standards are objectively right so when
this Pi Day the next time someone tells
you that you know we should really be
celebrating math on June 28th see how
quickly you can change the topic to one
where you're actually talking about a
piece of math
[Music]
you
[Music]